what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
that pregame
[Applause]
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos guys i
am back from the us and in the uk i have
de-transitioned
back into a woman um a fine one at that
period
um okay so today i have some special
guests on the channel um why don't we go
around to start everyone say your name
your age your relationship status and
where you're from
i can start um i am jessica i am from
uh california and
my relationship status is single
i am marcia i'm from portugal and i'm
single and yeah
um i'm lisey i'm from colombia and i'm
single
i'm iman i'm 21 years old i'm moroccan
and i'm single too
hi i'm neymar from london
nigerian jamaican
single with some complications
[Laughter]
what does that mean can i can i hear in
great detail
single with complications just meaning
that
um i'm heavily mingling oh heavily man
literally heavily
oh okay like you're in love
[Music]
i'm something
not that one
i got you i just like to be in the mix
you know
um okay guys so today's topic um is
johnny depp and amber hurd um so
the other day i was in my uber and i get
a text from my youtube manager and he
says make a video right now right now
the result is
the result is in and johnny depp won his
defamation suit against amber hurt so
depp sued for 50 million in damages over
a 2018 opinion editorial essay in the
washington post in which heard said she
had become a public figure representing
domestic abuse
and now in 2022 we found out this [ __ ]
was lying
um so
my question for today
is
now that the verdict has come out
do you think that this says something
about the metoo movement as a whole
i wouldn't say personally as a whole but
it definitely
sets it back a little bit because you'll
be given this platform
and
amber heard of pretty much abused it in
everything that it stands for and means
it can take a lot for someone that's
experienced
you know something along that line to
come out tell their story and you know
she's made a mockery of it to be
completely honest and that's why a lot
of people don't
get believed because of people like her
unfortunately
is there anyone here that like thinks
amber heard was telling the truth
okay i just want to make sure i didn't
think so
this is why i don't be good
now
do i think she was telling the truth no
however when you're in
in my opinion in a volatile relationship
or situation you know things do occur so
do i think that yeah she definitely
got over exaggerated with her story
hell yeah
however you know the details of exactly
what went on we will never know but
i do think there is some truth to some
of the volatile situations that happened
mm-hmm yeah yeah
yeah so you think do you do you think
that the volatile situations that
happened like it was him in self-defense
um i think a massive portion of it would
have been self-defense
most definitely
um
but you know when people are under the
influence of drugs alcohol
i mean you deal with a completely
different kettle of fish there so you
just you just don't know what anyone's
capable of until they're capable of it i
feel australian
so on some level you think she was
telling the truth a little bit um
i'd say like a one percent like well
okay but you you think she was mostly
like live most definitely yeah yeah that
was it the pooping the bad that did it
for you i mean the people that are stung
by me
all of that it was just it was just a
lot to take on and it's almost like
someone believe in their own lives and
when you believe your own lives
you're literally in la la land like she
is a resident at la la land forever in
my opinion
um what about you guys what do you think
this says about like the metoo movement
as a whole
and and talking to your pull your mic
close to you
pull it pull it closer yep yep okay
like that yeah yeah
um
so i'm not in favor of what she did what
she done uh of course not and i think
she's delusional
um but when it comes to the me too i
thought for a second it was just all
about the sexual harassment
but so
what she done to johnny depp as well is
inc so it's included on me too as well
just to be clear well okay so the reason
i should have prefaced this before yes
so the reason i said this is because
this was around 2016. and back then that
was
close to the time when like the
kavanaugh situation was going on and at
this point social media was like crazy
like i don't you remember this right
everyone was on social media writing me
too me too and they'd write a story
right that it happened to them happen to
them happen to them this sounds nice
except girls can now come forward with
no evidence
and ruin someone's reputation so
my point is if this happened to one of
like a powerful man in hollywood right
this happened to a guy with money and
resources and like
like he
an opportunity
what does this do to the average guy
like this had to have been going on all
across the country if this happened to
someone this powerful
so
in my opinion like i i don't think the
me too movement like i i think it was
more harmful to women than helpful
because now we have all these men coming
forward saying that
they were falsely accused
i mean it i think goes both ways it
might have truth and
not that true but i think the metoo
movement could be for both genders to
speak out not just for the female
like johnny depp did you know uh and i
think that's a great platform to share
your story
and even if it's true or it is a lie
eventually somehow we will know one day
sooner or one day later or maybe
sometimes it does happen
we think that's the truth and then it's
not
and probably we'll never know you know
but i guess that could happen anywhere
with anyone
and but the point is you're giving power
to people like the point is you're
giving power to people just on the basis
that they're a woman because it was
believe all women
yeah so so to me that's sexist like why
on earth would i believe all women
[ __ ] be crazy yes i mean i know some
crazy like some crazy girls that i would
not believe at all if they told me
something mm-hmm so like that movement
was saying believe all women
okay so the me too is like yeah
for me the me too it would be i was
seeing me too like for both genders that
would be great that'll be fair
you know to both genders come forward
and share their stories
and people would be inspired and they
would be comfortable to share their too
you know for me that would be great but
if it's just for women yeah i mean
that's unfair
and i think that's uh
hypocrites
yeah i mean
hypocritical yeah yeah i mean i feel
like
i don't feel like any specific movement
is meant to like live forever you know i
feel like any time that we have a
movement is sort of like to to rebalance
um disproportionate power you know so at
one point in time uh it was really hard
for women to come forward and say that
they had been uh sexually abused
but that the meeting movement sort of
like helped a lot of women come forward
but
it's only a matter of time before it
starts going the other way you know and
the power starts becoming
disproportionate in the you know in the
in the favor of women so i feel like um
the metoo movement has served this
purpose in a way the same way that
feminism served its purpose at one point
but it's like okay like we can move on
from it now because if we keep like
you know saying like hashtag me to
hashtag believe women like it becomes
the kind of thing where people take
advantage of it well i think people took
advantage of it to begin with like it
was all started off of like kavanaugh
there they never pressed charges against
him
and that's what started it all
yeah and and to me it's like should we
believe people if there's no evidence
should we give them should we give a
microphone to anyone who has a story
even though even if there's no evidence
is my question but sometimes you cannot
prove there's stories out there that you
cannot prove any they are true you know
it happens in some people's life that
you cannot prove
and you know and it is truth and as well
there's some stories as well you cannot
prove and it's a lie yeah it goes both
ways right right so that's why i'm
saying like it should be like it totally
does go both ways like men lie women
like people lie people are people yeah
but my point is i don't think we should
give a microphone to anybody that
doesn't have proof
like i don't think like
me and jess were friends right and if
she came forward and said something
happened to her i would believe her but
i just think as like a media outlet like
i do media now i can't give a microphone
to someone that has no proof i think
that's irresponsible
yeah it makes sense
so you agree with that you agree with
that i i
just want to add that
the founders and the people involved in
the metoo movement
this is like a lesson learned do due
diligence because
unfortunately people can lie people can
say whatever they want to say but
for such it's like such a big media
outlet that has such an influence they
have to be doing due diligence and how
this has been allowed to happen i'm just
like
well i think it's because we we live in
a gynocentric social order yeah like
women women run everything
women run the media we make 70 to 80 of
consumer buying decisions okay so like
that everything we see in the media
caters to women yeah
like i don't even really see the need
for feminism nowadays because i i think
in 2022 like we're it's almost anti-men
it's not even like for a woman yeah i
created enzyme and how we scrutinize
like look i mean because look at this
this was feminism this was an example
this was a movement like that was
this was a feminism movement
and look what it did to men
yeah and now we're seeing the
repercussions of that later does anyone
disagree with that
no no i think that um
there's a lot of things that
start off for good but people hop on it
and just join the bandwagon and they're
like oh me too me too me too me to me
too not saying everybody but i feel like
with these big movements that happen
like um i won't even mention any because
i don't want no i want no smoke
it's the big one so me too and then blm
um i think
they
when they started had a maybe a good
concept why they started it but then
they didn't regulate it in any way and
they just let anybody and everybody do
and they're like oh well they're
supporting us so it's good and not
seeing the repercussions of like the
negative that could have happened if
someone comes on they're like me too
and
i've seen it happen with pro athletes
with high school athletes college
athletes trying to
increase their um their livelihood in
their sport and someone comes up and
says oh this person did that did this to
me now they're in they're serving time
in jail and then when they get out
there's like oh um you actually didn't
do it sorry and it's like you can't you
can't just say sorry and wipe your hands
of that that's ruining someone's life
this is just destroying it completely
now they have to start all over they
don't have either the scholarships or
the contracts that they have before and
that's just like a small percentage of
them but it it's a lot
to falsely accuse somebody of this just
to
do it
um i guess actually um people now want
to be famous for no reason everyone
wants to be famous and you don't need
resources to actually be famous these
days you just need phone and good
network and then boom that's it like
tick tock is free youtube is free
instagram is free people would just make
any they would just watch movies and
make any script in their head and
discuss just go for it and that's how
they will end up to be famous even if
it's to gain sympathy or pity or just to
be even if they are not true so why
wouldn't they take it as an advantage to
themselves which is wrong to the person
who would be falsely accused but it
would be good for them because they will
gain they will even gain money fame
everything they want so why not you know
yeah so it's a it's like a good tool in
their hands to take advantage of
yeah because there's like there's a lot
of power in victimhood you know yeah
that's what sort of drove amber to keep
going at it like i feel like when she
received all the support at the
beginning and she became this kind of
like the face of me too
i mean that that gave her like
a big brush and
yeah exactly in power so it's like you
know that that crew ups your mind in a
way like and once you get a taste of
that like i feel like she just couldn't
let it go and i feel like that's why she
might be you know
appealing at this whole thing it's like
she just wants to keep the train rolling
yeah because even bad attention like is
still attention you know what i mean
yeah exactly 100 percent i want to read
her
let me go to her instagram her
freaking
okay so she posted after the trial
the disappointment i feel today is
beyond words i'm heartbroken that the
mountain of evidence
this is my first time reading it still
was not enough to stand up to the
disproportionate power influence and
sway of my ex-husband ma'am you chopped
his finger off like what okay i'm even
more disappointed with
what with what this verdict means for
other women is it
it is a setback it sets back the clock
to a time when a woman who spoke up and
spoke out could be publicly shamed and
humiliated it sets back the idea that
violence against women is to be taken
seriously i believe johnny's attorneys
succeeded in getting the jury to
overlook the key issue of freedom of
speech and ignore the evidence that was
so conclusive that we even won in the uk
i'm sad i lost this case but i am sadder
that i still
i am sadder still that i seem to have
lost a right i thought i had as an
american to speak freely and openly
[Laughter]
she set herself back
you made your bed now you have to lie in
it
like it's just a mockery to the whole
thing and then to be trying to drag
other women into your whatever speech
that was leave us out of it we're good
ma'am you're the problem
you set back women right
i mean
just her victim complex to me is just
she's dangerous she is she's so
dangerous yeah because even though after
the conclusion she if i was in her place
i would turn off the wi-fi like for a
month or a year you know and turn off my
account and be like
no goodbye world bye-bye
you know but no she has like the gut to
post something like that and just keep
going and that's i call it the audacity
yeah exactly i think she sounds very
nice narcissist she taught me she is she
is like the definition of being a
narcissist it's almost like
maybe in the time span of their
relationship
one incident happened and she has
completely dramatized that incident and
replayed it in her mind and it's just
it's just crazy i guess she loved the
attention though because this whole
thing made her even a bigger public
figure yeah she literally loved the
attention she wants she wanted it to
carry on and on and on so she can
actually come out do a bit of over drama
over reactions and then get detention
from people so
everybody everybody knew who johnny depp
was
everybody loved johnny depp captain jack
sparrow everything everybody knew him
and they're like who's amber
[Laughter]
now that this case has come out
everyone's like
oh amber this amber that looking up
videos and it's just it's just like a
revenue for her and it's just feeding
into her her ego for lack of better
words for all of this and i just
it's so
amazing how some people can
make up a lie
and we hear it and it's like you got
stung by a bee
your dog died and you pooped in the bed
how what what does that what does it
have to do with anything
and it's like the way she's telling it
yeah she was like
when she was talking about uh johnny
grabbed my hair and
he was and it's just like ma'am this was
just like if you come on
did you go through it or not yes you may
be traumatized but you you're pausing as
if you're making it up and the way
you're talking about it i've seen so
many videos people are like oh he
slapped me and then i turned around and
people reenacting it and i'm like if you
look at me doesn't make sense it doesn't
make sense it's like
they're facing the opposite way and
she's like johnny why did you slap me
and it's just like it's
just people's minds are just
just
a whole world in itself to be able to
make up a lie keep going with it and
believe it and you're like everybody
should believe it because i believe it
have you ever met one of those people in
real life i'm thinking of a specific man
right i'm thinking of a dude who is like
this
and
no no not like that crazy like he was
saying someone beat him but just like
have you ever met like a pathological
liar and you're like how do you lie that
fast no i haven't really never eaten you
yeah
this girl she would
one day her dad was in the hospital and
then her mum was in the hospital and
then this person had this and this
person had that and the first couple of
times you're like oh my god i'm so
concerned and then the next couple of
times you're like jesus christ
like you when it rains it literally
pours and you're getting soaked like
what is going on with you
the um and it's crazy because amber
heard reportedly plans to appeal against
johnny depp defamation verdict
the actor amber hurd is reported to be
planning an appeal after losing
a defamation trial against her former
husband johnny depp over allegations of
sexual abuse
no sorry domestic not sexual um domestic
abuse jurors in a virginia court ruled
in favor of death um on three counts
awarding the pirates of the caribbean
actor 15 million which was later reduced
by the judge to 10.35 million
do you feel like that was a fair
punishment i think she should have
gotten more yeah like is 10 point
whatever even gonna cover his lawyers or
like is it i'm confused i don't know
because this case went on for a long
time really it was 15 million it was
like 10 million for like his and uh yeah
five minutes next reward and five
million for the punitive something yeah
i i think they should sue the the
company that published the op-ed too i
think that was really irresponsible as a
journalist
so i work in media i wouldn't like
that's so irresponsible because that's a
that's a big thing to be like
yes if it's some small person be like
okay we can
uh publish this but it's johnny depp and
that that article took him off of the
pirates of the caribbean because of that
and this is like
do you realize how
like big that is for that article
to then get to the um production company
of pirates of the caribbean to take him
take him
johnny depp who
in my opinion made pirates of the
caribbean take him out of it to where
he's not in it anymore that's huge so i
think however much they were going to
pay him in that production company for
the movie for the time for everything
post uh production everything i think
she should have to pay i think she
should go to jail yeah i think she
should go to jail because you're taking
that man's lively like i think that's
what she did was meaner
that like
if someone told me okay you could either
spend two years in jail and come out or
you for the next decade of your life you
can't do media you can't do any of the
[ __ ] that you love i would pick two
years in jail
yeah other than like because she took
away the one thing that he loves doing
like that gives him life but now he's
gonna have way more jobs you know
because now he got his repetition a
reputation back the thing is i think
amber is really dumb because she will
never get a job as an actor i don't
think so
you know she she didn't have many jobs
with an actress exactly but i think in
the future like she would not even be
you know allowed in the in the
productions or even in in tv you know
and you know who she is before this game
to be honest yeah i think she actually
helped him like she i mean she didn't
have any he didn't need any help of
course because he's a great actor and he
always had you know fame he'll never get
that series back i know i know i'm not
saying that i'm saying amber i think
she's really dumb she really damaged her
career there was like just like this
this much that is none like it's not
existing
you know damage is done isn't it and in
regards to that report that you guys
were mentioning before speaking to the
mic the reporter sorry you were
mentioning before
we live in a society where you can
literally just post an apology like what
repercussion is she actually gonna have
she could just oh yeah i apologize like
apologies seem to go far it's just
ridiculous yeah just not enough and yeah
he might be able to get contracts back
but the damage has been done since when
did they divorce in 2016.
when did they divorce i think it was
2016.
i think the op-ed maybe was in 2016. i
don't i don't know exactly that's five
in this case
yeah it says it says here 2016 divorce
yeah i think this is the case what
five years and even
with the trial like it's so evasive some
of the details that you
heard about their relationship so it's i
don't know i don't know how easy it will
be for him to
build his reputation back up because
five years is such a long time to be
defamed like that i'm not saying that he
won't but it's not going to be easy
it's not
well and um
like now he had to bring all this
personal stuff
out into the light that i'm sure he
didn't want of course he doesn't want to
know he just want the world to know that
his wife his ex-wife was beating him
yeah like guys that's i mean that can be
embarrassing for guys it's really sad
but i've talked to guys about this no no
guy wants the world to know that their
girl beating is beating them up yeah
you know you know it's an interesting
stat that i just found out the other
other day this was on my story
the majority of domestic violence cases
both parties are abusing each other so
it's not just like one-sided and the
majority like they're both abusing each
other
and um when it is one-sided 70 of the
time it's women abuse hitting the men
and then and the men not hitting them
back so the majority of domestic abuse
cases are actually that are that are
one-sided where they're not both doing
it are actually like the women hitting
the men
yeah i i think there is more emotional
damage when a man does to a woman and
then a woman reacts probably more
physically physical
to react over emotional because i heard
a lot of stories a lot of a lot of women
and they you know we are more emotional
and men are more rational and i think
men are more aware as well if they get
emotional and physical they will get in
a lot of trouble so it's more smart to
emotional damage a woman than actually
physical because there is no marks there
is no wounds that you can see you know
physical in a way
so there's that's way more smart and
there's a lot of narcissist people out
there as a man and as a woman so men
that's not true that's a very small
percentage of the population as
narcissists what do you mean it's it's
it's comparing women to men or no no
just in general in general like if you
survey a like [ __ ] like if you study a
hundred people like that's not true good
you just ran that's good
yeah yeah maybe you like them i don't
know
but
i i met one you know i know i'm now i'm
like huh
i met a guy i'm like
i remember i got the ikino i'm like is
this one narcissist or not you know i'm
like always scanning now in my mind
because you're living out of fear though
because i just got out of a traumatic
experience you know but you realize like
if you make the next guy pay for it
there won't be an x guy
yeah true cuz like it's like a guy like
looking through your phone because his
last girlfriend she did
yeah you know like you're like what did
i do
[Laughter]
i just feel like i'm now i'm blessing
with holy water every day you know
sage and everything not anymore honestly
because it was my first and last
and last narcissist
but
what i'm saying is i think i think
though back to like the conversation is
that
women should be afraid to hit men and
we're not
well women should be afraid to hit him
like like the way that men know that if
they hit a woman their ass is going to
jail like women should have that same
fear because it's not okay
yes
and like there was a guy who just died
the other day because his
his wife like beat him to death
basically yeah and she walked
and there's no outrage yeah what yeah
she didn't got
jail time the same thing like what
happened with the actor or the um only
fans model in florida
oh she yeah like she killed she killed
her boyfriend oh yeah yeah
and she walked and even because there
were some reports that maybe like they
were both like again the majority of
domestic abuse cases they're abusing
each other like it's usually not just
one but even say that was happening like
if we reverse the roles right and he
killed her
he would not have walked but she does
and it's just like we live in this
society where like women are just
like babied honestly just because we're
women and i'm so tired of these hoes
and we're not dainty at all i completely
agree with that statement i don't know
why it's like that it's ridiculous
because we've come so far with these
metoo movements and
you know women having more power girl
power power to the people and all of
that stuff but then we're still treated
you know like back in the 60s or 50s
yeah i think
i think women
hit men because they know they're not
going to get in trouble i'm like
look
if you hit if you hit anybody
it's fair game i i don't care you asked
for it like if you're going to hit
somebody
you're opening the door for them to hit
come back and hit you
it's it's a hard reality to understand
but you shouldn't hit somebody and not
uh expect somebody to retaliate on you
you're putting them in a position to
where they're gonna have to let their
anger out some other way and you may not
know how that way is going to happen and
it comes back and it's worse than if
they would have hit you and so i don't i
don't think anybody should hit anybody
unless you want the repercussions of if
you hit somebody
if it's to protect yourself always
defend yourself because you should if
it's self you know i understand it's
self defense definitely
um but if it's not of course i'm not i'm
not a person that is violent i don't
like to attack people i don't like to
you know act on
being physical but
i
um
i had an experience and i have to
self-defense myself
and yeah i almost kill him
almost don't get scared
i didn't kill him and i didn't walk away
okay
don't worry i didn't got there
no
it's scary
but i had to protect myself
okay if it's self-defense it was so
different that's a whole different thing
yes but i i honestly used to think i
used to at one point thing never hit a
woman like that was my yeah but i really
did until i saw how these [ __ ] be
hidden i was like i thought they were
like hey like a play fight no no no no
hold on switch oh you're gonna come at
him like a man expect to get decked like
a man
like what the what are you doing i think
a lot of that as well for some women
that attack men or whatever the
situation is trauma
mental health
the way that you've been brought up your
characteristics a lot of that stuff does
play a part into it as well it's not
just a case of oh yeah i'm gonna do this
because i can get away with it because
i'm a woman
you know i've
personally been in some volatile
relationships situations no i don't
think that it's
okay to hit anyone but i know personally
i've had some authentications because of
past trauma yeah
there's no really way to put it into
words but you just your mind takes you
to a place and it's not that oh yeah i
think i can hit a man it's just you like
go into
mad mode i just
pump it in any other way than that wait
so did you hit him so let's say for
example i've had a past relationship
where you know there was domestic
violence involved
um fast forward into a new relationship
because i didn't allow myself to heal
didn't give myself closure i had ptsd
and issues that i didn't even realize i
was not working through so
when a particular argument would happen
with my new partner it's like i was
waiting for some sort of reaction that i
wasn't going to get so that just made me
act out but again that was down to
me not getting the closure and dealing
with trauma that when i was in denial
what did you say act out do you mean hit
him or was it like well it was a very
volatile relationship um the previous
one right but the new guy when he used
to yell
i just used to feel that oh my god
something's about to happen so i kind of
want to get in there first now that's by
no means okay to put your hands on
anyone but yeah unfortunately that's the
the sad truth of some of my past certain
situations that have happened that have
made me
overreact and you know do you know
what's interesting though in this
situation like if you were a dude saying
the same thing i feel like the reaction
would be completely different yeah like
you know i mean like if he said like oh
because of my trash trauma i felt like
she was going to come at me first so i
like decked her i hit her yeah it's just
interest like like this is just
like and i'm not trying to like you know
shame you know but it's just it's just
like i think that's how our society is
it's very like woman-centric yes and it
almost allows us to like get away with
bad behavior yeah most definitely like
i'll be the first to say i don't condone
any of that
bad behavior whatsoever but i have to be
a realist and accept the fact that a b
and c could have happened because i
didn't internally deal with some of my
issues and it's all down to me it's not
down to the other person it's not even
down to my ex who did whatever he did to
me it comes down to me really so that's
like healing that i had to
find for myself yeah and that's that's
good because a lot of girls will
continue to blame other people instead
of like taking that accountability yeah
you can't yeah but before in the society
it was men centric as well
now it's women-centric if you if you
think that you know if you think through
actually back in the day it was meant
century and still there's a lot of power
how would you say it was men centric
back in the day
uh because women they would not have the
right
i mean to work they would stay like at
home being a housewife they would be
mothers and they had to clean they had
to cook and shut up
they would never had the power to choose
a lot of stuff the men would they would
the men had to give permission you know
this is like back back in the day i'm
saying you realize they got to stay home
and they got to not work
like that that's a privilege to be a
housewife that's a privilege that's a
privilege for a lot of women out there
but not all women i think everyone there
is there's accounts of girls in the
1800s in the us becoming like
millionaires self-made
yeah
i mean
everyone is different and just because
we are women doesn't mean that we want
the same thing you know there's a lot of
women they don't want to have kids
there's a lot of women they don't want
to marry and that's okay and we need to
accept that because just because you are
a woman it doesn't mean that you have to
be a housewife because you are a man it
doesn't mean that you have to be a
husband there's a lot of people out
there this is not about gender it's
about humans and humans are complicated
and we are all different and we have
different ones well okay and we have to
accept that so i'm just going to throw
some numbers at you okay so the average
person i don't know so this is just i
think this is a reality that a lot of
women don't know and i think a lot of
people like think like like think like
you i don't fault you for that but okay
you realize the average person needs 2.5
million to retire so if you want to
retire at 65 and you don't want to work
the rest of your life you need 2.5
million
so that means that 65 if you if you want
enough money to not be you know taken
out by a cancer diagnosis or something
and you can't do that unless you make
i don't know the exact number but it's
about it's about six figures or more
and you need two incomes to do that
and another like thing that people don't
know is that women that don't have kids
and don't get married they're
statistically one of the most unhappy
groups
but it's their choice
not just no no i'm not it's not judging
it's like giving girls the information
because because we a lot of times in
society we'll say oh don't judge like do
what you want and i'm and i'm all for
that if a girl wants to do that but if
you end up homeless and alone i don't
think you're going to be very happy and
a lot of women are heading towards that
because they're not prioritizing family
there's a lot of men as well doing that
you know there's a lot of men now they
are probably going to places or not
and they don't want a girl they don't
want girl they want girlfriends actually
they want wives yes they do exactly they
want wives in plural not seeing they
don't want a wife they want wives well
okay so another does that make sense
another stat that a lot of people don't
know is that it's a very small
percentage of men that have access to
all of the women
so when women talk about 80 of women if
you ask them what they want in a man
what they would need to like marry a
dude or be with a dude they list 20 of
men and that's on the high end sometimes
it's 5 sometimes it's 10 sometimes it's
15
so the men that you're talking about
that want three wives um the majority of
men would be happy with any wife
they would just be happy with anyone
because the majority one in three men
under 30 aren't haven't slept with
anyone in the past year or are virgins
yeah so so men but the thing is men
historically have been lonely like men
men historically don't always reproduce
because historically only 40 percent of
men reproduced where 80 of women did
so
like like that that's normal for me i'm
not saying it's okay or right like but
like that's that's normal throughout
history what's not normal is telling
women to like chase the bad priority
prioritize a career over a family and
then
now she's 60 alone and homeless
and
all because like she was given the wrong
advice
yeah she she's homeless yeah because you
need 2.5 million to retire so if you're
like let's say you stay by yourself and
you make it to 60 or 65 okay
and you get a cancer diagnosis that will
put you on the street
or you get or you get you know you have
too much debt like the other issue is
that women own the majority of debt so
i don't remember the exact stat but it's
like 75 to 80 of debt is owned by women
so this is this is the path and half of
women over 30 are single and childless
and 90 of your eggs are gone by 30.
so the path that a lot of women are
taking is to be homeless they're the
largest growing number of homeless
population
but not just women as well men oh no men
too but the thing is like women have a
choice a lot of men don't
because a lot of men are short they're
unattractive like that's true i mean i'm
not saying but it is scary for women as
well to create a family in these days
with this kind of men there's a lot of
men are behaving like women and women
are behaving like men
so we are chasing the bag yes because we
met a lot of men they are just like [ __ ]
boys you know and they just wanted they
they pretend to lure you in with you
know presents and love bombing but you
realize like we we choose the men that
are [ __ ] boys we choose them because we
we overlook 80 percent of men
we overlook there's a there's a
so how many [ __ ] boys in your percentage
is you know
how many what do you know how many [ __ ]
players are out there and many good okay
let me know i'm interested so when i let
me know where when i think of a [ __ ] boy
i think of a guy that's talking and
sleeping with multiple girls right would
you say that's what you would define as
ah
okay i had a [ __ ] why he was only
sleeping with me but okay and he become
you wanted to yeah sorry because he was
playing 24 7 with me so
definitely he was only sleeping with me
no menage a trois no no threesome
how is he a fuckboy though yeah i need
to know this
the behavior because sometimes
for example we would go out and he would
try to make me jealous or playing like
mind games okay so he's crazy
so he's not [ __ ] okay so fuckboy is
[ __ ] pretty people only that when i
think when i think about
when i think of a [ __ ] boy i think of
a guy that's sleeping with multiple
women like that's because when i when
yeah but he was a [ __ ] boy before he met
me he told me like he was [ __ ] every
every other girl every weekend yes so so
that's what i would do so what i'm
saying is there's a very small
percentage of men that have the
opportunity to do that so for example if
you want a guy that's a i'm six foot i
would prefer a guy that's taller than me
i mean if i want a guy that's taller
than me that's 15 of the population
let's say half of those guys are broke
because let's say let's say half a rich
half are broke that's another half
that's that's so half of 15 is 7.5
percent right so that's 7.5 percent of
the you're looking for
and it's probably even smaller than that
so what i'm saying is we pick and that's
that's a superficial thing right looking
for height that's super fit it's okay i
like it too i'm not no yeah no
me and you if we wanted we could pick a
short king that would be faithful to us
but we just choose not to
so i can't put it on the men if we're
the ones picking those guys and we're
all picking the same guys
yeah it's like you're blocking your own
blessing really yeah by
overlooking what you might not go for
for what you would normally go for so
yeah we kind of like hindered ourselves
yeah
yeah and so i like i have a lot of
empathy because i i think a lot of girls
don't know this
yeah yeah like that's what
yeah i mean i feel like there's this
thing being pushed
um on social media and
it's like the the sort of like hookup
culture and and the
the sort of
advice that girls are given that they
should go out and experiment a lot and
sort of like get to know what they like
and i feel like
by the point that you finish feeling
like you you got to know what you like
you actually got to know what you don't
like and by that i mean like you
experience things that left you
traumatized and left you with a lot of
baggage that
you're gonna you know take on to your
next relationships like and
and you know take it out on guys um that
don't deserve it like i've personally
experienced this and in the sense that
one guy like you know turns out to be a
[ __ ] boy and then like i just feel like
this need of like revenge with like the
rest of like the male population like
you know i i feel like it's a natural
thing and like obviously i know that
it's not
you know it's not valid and like i've
i've worked through that but um and that
way i feel like
that did harm me you know and and
sometimes i wish that i wouldn't like
have bought into that like oh just go
out and get to know what you like
because
you don't really need to like
it's uh i think it's more fun i guess i
guess we actually focus on the minority
that actually posts in social media
and then we relate all of with all of
them like oh my gosh she's a girl she
had this case i have the same i'm
feeding her and like we all like
generalize that the whole world is like
that is negative everyone is just bad
just by focusing on the minority that
are highlighting their experiences over
social media but we forget that there is
a majority that maybe did not are not
like that and did not face whatever
these people have faced right and maybe
there there are good people some
somewhere but just because we focus on
what is superficial as you said and we
focus on these people that had maybe we
can relate with them maybe you know when
these posts come out in your field and
be like oh have you been teaching none
have you been blah blah blah we just
focus on that instead of focusing that
maybe we have other people that are good
and haven't had that and can't harm me
either so that's how maybe we just look
at the like negative side instead of
just um we just overlook at the negative
side basically instead of just looking
at a bright side yeah
and just because of the way the
algorithm works in social media usually
the stories that are pushed out are like
the most like extreme exactly you know
what i mean so we feel like we're
getting the whole picture but we're
actually not we're getting like the
minority that is like extreme cases
and i think that
feminism
it could have been done so much better
and with like telling women about these
stats instead of saying chase the bag
all about women women and women instead
of and they should have told women about
these stats like if you want this high
value man or blah blah blah blah
whatever it is saying like there's a
small pot be realistic
you need the if you want a family if you
want to have this
lifestyle white picket fence all that
good stuff realistically by 30 if you
don't have it your
ex the
the um the image is going to get smaller
and smaller because
after 30
clock is ticking clock is ticking and
this that little small
small stat i think would have changed
the mind of a lot of women instead of
i'm just gonna focus on my career
everything and then i'll focus on
relationship and teaching them how to
balance things i think a lot of women
would be further along in their careers
and their lives and everything in their
happiness if
feminism if that movement was more
truthful and honest up front with how
can we be
are
like a woman but also succeed be
successful in all these areas and come
out happy on the end instead of just
saying bump all men
we're the best species in the world and
this is how we become the best species
it's like we both need each other men
and women both need each other to exist
i think that it just could have been
yeah i actually believe also that
because this thing that the clock is
ticking right and then women oh this 30s
30s they end up actually choosing drunk
person and then when they choose the
wrong person and have the
like most miserable experience in their
lives they actually think that everyone
is just like that
but they do not actually realize that
there are so many circumstances that
push them to choose the wrong person
first of all it's just this whole thing
oh the clock is ticking i don't have
time anymore and i need to rush i need
so whatever comes in that picture you
just choose that person and maybe end up
in the wrong situation that would
actually just give them the whole
picture of everything is wrong well i
think they're rushed because they didn't
prioritize marriage right exactly yeah
they made that choice and so then it's
like
as a woman like i just think when you're
and i say this like you know i'm not
married and i and i feel and i'm 25. and
and i it's like because as a woman you
know you you only have so much time and
if you wait too long and you don't pick
somebody like you're gonna end up not
having kids and to me like my life would
be purposeless if i didn't have kids it
would be to me it's like who cares about
a good career if you don't have someone
to share it with i feel like it's such a
double-edged sword though because yeah
when you're out looking for a partner
like the last thing you want to be is
desperate you know what i mean like the
last thing you want to do is go out
there with this fear-based mentality
that the clock is sticking like i have
to prioritize this because
you know like that's not gonna get you
the results that you want either
that's actually gonna make it worse you
know so so it's a balance you know on
one hand it's like you can't be like oh
yeah i just focus on my career
in my 20s and then like in my 30s like
the right man will appear because you
know that that that's a fantasy and but
also on the other hand you can't just
like be out there being like the clock
is sticking where my mind you know what
i mean i think it's i think it's like
dating with intention
so like like i i don't know about you
but i have definitely wasted time with
with a guy that i knew was not my
husband i'm there i i have a hundred
percent done that because i was too
attached and i didn't want to leave yeah
and so then it's like we get closer and
closer to our 30s like let's say 35 like
after 35 your chance of kids is tough
like that's that's when it becomes a
geriatric pregnancy
and the average um i know they talk
about ivf but the average person doesn't
have 25 000 laying around to do it
so for the average person it's basically
over at 35.
so
we waste our 20s with these guys we
shouldn't be with and then expect our
husbands to pick up the pieces after
yeah yeah yeah and that's not really
fair to them
because you know if we overlook those
guys in our 20s and then say oh here i
am at like 30 something damage please
take me i'm don't don't get me wrong
some of y'all still do
but it's not like a good way to go into
a marriage and i i'm not like i don't
you know i don't think we should all be
married at like 18 but i think there's
some balance because your options this
is another thing they don't tell you
your options decrease by 50 by the time
you're 30. so if they took your dating
app matches when you were
20 versus 30 it's 50 less by the time
you're 30. i'm just gonna give up by
this time i ain't trying i'm closing
that's where i as a fellow
clock ticker because i am over 30 i
could definitely like over 30. oh wow
girl
so yeah i definitely like agree with a
lot of the points that you guys have
said since i turned 30 there definitely
is like
in the back of my mind what you doing
girl like literally don't have all the
time in the world but then in my 20s
i enjoyed playing the field dating and
seeing what happens but i do think that
it's a shame that
it's like you said there should be a
balance you shouldn't see it as just one
or the other because some people see
success
being making money others see it through
family through friends whatever you yes
class success is so i definitely agree
there should be some sort of narrative
where you know you can actually
have it all if you are willing to invest
that time into it i don't think you can
have it all i think that's the lie that
feminism says you think i think you can
have it
who but not at the same time no i i just
like okay i think you can have it all
but like gradually yeah moderation
moderation no i think that's i know
life's about trade-offs and choices so
like i grew up in a one percent family
like my parents are like very well off
my my mom and my dad met young they
married they had they have 10 kids
and on paper they have it all but what
you don't see is you know there's
choices and trade-offs that came with it
i didn't see my dad for a lot of my
childhood right i didn't see my mom for
a lot of my childhood they worked so
much and that was a trade-off it's fine
i don't have college debt so i'm fine
with it but
but
you know we tell we tell women that
there's no trade-off and you can just
have everything and that's a one percent
of the population that did and they
barely did
and you know and even with your talking
about playing the field
that you know what the consequence for
playing the field is if you're a virgin
when you get married your chance of a
happy marriage is is around
i'm butchering this but around 80
percent these
statistics if you sleep with more than
five people it goes down to 25 jesus
so your chances
five people yeah over five people it
goes down to twenty five percent fifteen
and it's because and it's because it's
well it's because like think about it
when you've experienced more men like
you compare the next guy to him so your
husband like like each guy each guy you
sleep with you might think oh i liked
that about him i liked that about him i
liked that about him and then the next
guy
he has all these standards to live up to
i learned the great lesson about that
okay i went to my great guy
you know okay
a few
weeks ago
it turned out it was my worst guy
my worst guy
so people change you know and i think we
have to accept that so please don't
believe the the best guy that you had
five years ago
he's the best and will be the best maybe
maybe he's mad because you left him
what maybe he's not the best guy because
you left him why the hell would he be
the best guy now
no i i didn't like so it wasn't
there's the last podcast you said you
left it no that's my eggs oh it's not
that was not my background i need you to
get closer to them i wish that was my
best at least i would have a
you know a good deja vu a recent good
deja vu no no no i wish that was my best
but no it wasn't i think
okay
okay there's a couple exes here that i
think i'm maybe okay only three okay i
thought you said the nice one yeah that
was like the nicest one it was
seven-year-old i mean seven year uh
relationship that i had with him i lived
with him i lived with him back in
switzerland for seven years that i have
nothing to say he's a great man
a great man that's not the one you went
back to no so why didn't you he's
getting married if you were going back
to the nice guy why didn't you go back
to the act no no my great sex let's say
he was the greatest sex he's a bad guy
so there's three guys only in my life so
you know what i mean like that that was
the great sex that uh that's the first
when i was 17 yeah 17 greatest sex in my
whole life you know like they turned
like a chicken liking on the grill
so he turned me like a chicken on the
grill you know i still have those
memories but once i went back there
a few weeks then i was like
no chicken in the grill
what the [ __ ]
oh like the size it wasn't it was sex oh
my god it was me in a church with no
people there
wait we don't care
it was like probably i will see a
mosquito let me let me let me understand
i'm crying
so wait let me let me understand this
did you you slept with him in the church
or you've got him
no i'm not a sinner not like that i am a
senior sometimes everyone is come on
but i own it and yeah um so after the
last show you thought let's go back to
the the best guy and
but i thought you meant like the nicest
the best boyfriend but the nicest
boyfriend you meant the best sex yeah
like what's happening it was for nine
months oh it was kind of a relationship
no okay so so so you after the last
podcast you said let me hit him up and
then you slept with him again and it was
bad
no okay the last guy i was talking the
last podcast it was my recent x okay
that's my third right the third the
the first one it was my greatest sex
okay i was 17 great sex
i i went back there after 10 years after
10 years i was like okay now i'm single
you know i know i don't want a life with
him i don't want nothing with him but
you know it's good to go in the chicken
on the grill again so why you can't
raise your body i'm never getting a
chicken
you know you know when you have a good
sex and you feel alive after 10 years
why not
oh you were still you were still
worrying about him after 10 years
after 10 years yes so on facebook he
looked like the same you look good you
know
so i i met him i even traveled oh my god
if i tell you the story girls how far
did you travel
luxembourg
where where but he played the flight
like some birds yeah
but then i took a train and buzzed four
hours from there
it was mad
no chicken on a grill
not worth it not worth it not even if he
paid me a million i would go again
no no no his mental heal like in his
head
and um the sex was the worst like i
could count mosquitoes i could i could
be like on my head okay today is monday
uh-huh what time is it okay what did i
do today okay i probably cooked you know
like when you have good sex you don't
think about that you're in the moment
right you're like there but when you
have bad sex you think oh my god i have
to pay my bills i have to clean the
house i have lunch to do oh my god
tomorrow i have school so you're never
going through your daily tasks during
your like writing and just thinking
about okay [ __ ] is going on the way that
i came here and i was about to stay four
days and the next day i just left how'd
i get here move
run
run
do you not see how like it proves the
point that like
the first time or i don't know if it was
the first time but the time you had sex
with your best
to the time that you recently had sex
with him you you having multiple like
partners within that time has
now upped your experience yes so i
learned a great lesson and then now
you're in that situation where like
what was once your best moment has kind
of been ruined because you now know so
much more yeah so
if you married the first guy the memory
of the greatest sex that i had with him
is not it's not the leader and will
never be
but then you're going into you're going
into different relationships having that
image in your head yeah these guys
aren't and that's the mistake girls
ladies don't do that yes
because that's a trap that's a big trap
don't do it you know because we compare
and that's the thing you were saying
before like we compare like the like the
guy that we had now that we have now to
the last one that we had and that's bad
girls because people change and
look at me after 10 years i went back
worse sex
don't do it like don't
don't think like the the grass is
greener in the other side never
never i'm gonna tell you and that's the
problem in this generation right now
with instagram and all that people get
attempted about photos and naked girls
and naked guys and they think oh that's
you know that's better or that's hotter
and then there's a lot of cheating
because we think always the green is the
green in the other side is is
the grass is green
the grass is greener in the other side
so please girls don't do that to
yourselves you're gonna traumatize
yourself i did already i did for all
girls you see i sacrificed myself to
tell you girls no don't do it you know
really that was not the message i was
hoping you got out of this podcast
i i thought you were gonna maybe try to
rekindle with the ex that was like nice
to you i know he's he's about to get
married and even though if he was single
i wouldn't because
um i really broke up with him you like
the narcissist it's a little bit
no
i think you do
keep going back to no because the first
guy you see 10 years ago he was a great
guy he's from portugal he was like
neighbors with my family like
and
he's been living with his mom so he's
been well raised but since he moved out
i think he kind of fall apart with his
how you say values her values i think he
kind of forgot those values
and i just felt completely
um
lost with him like i felt somehow
i was not with a guy that i met 10 years
ago
i thought he was a different person the
way he act the way he talked
and no no i thought he was a great
person back then and he was he was
um but now
he's chicken yeah this is the other
thing
okay yeah okay so but the point the
point is like sleeping with multiple
people does impact your ability to pair
bond yeah i didn't sleep with much
people why no but it doesn't i didn't
say i don't know i'm not that i didn't
say how many i said more than one
oh okay yeah like yeah because even even
when you no no i'm not
i'm not making a judgment on what is a
lot that's not my point okay is the more
people that you sleep with the harder
it's going to be for a guy to get
married to you
and that's not a fun truth i don't think
that because i think as women like we're
forced to make decisions a lot sooner
than men and you're given a lot of
attention from a young age
especially if you're like a very pretty
girl like at like 15 you have guys
hitting on you all the time i think
girls have to make decisions quick yes
but i i think it's dishonest to say
there's no consequences to like sleeping
with multiple people because there are
and at least as women like we can have
this conversation and like be honest to
the next generation of women
definitely because yeah because that's
that's my problem is a lot of feminism
it
it promotes do what you want with your
body
but in a way that's almost encouraging
girls to be to be [ __ ] honestly it's
not like it's not you know like when
you're having a a tip march what what
the hell else are you supposed to call
that like like the patriarchy disguising
itself is feminism like if you're using
feminist terms
because it's like you know if there's
men out there that like want to have sex
with girls like what best way to like
get them to have sex with them then tell
them like it's cool like you know what i
mean like it's feminist to like be
sleeping around with people you know
what i mean i feel like or very sexy
yeah it's like more in favor of men than
it is on women because then it also
weakens you as a woman you know as a as
we said before like it can um
it can damage you it can uh affect your
self-worth whether you want to accept it
or or not
and then you're going to also like lower
your standards you know
and just and go for anything and in
regards to what we were saying earlier i
feel like not only do we compare but we
also romanticize the past so it's not
that that other person was necessarily
better but when you're in a situation in
the present you're very aware of the
positive and the negative and sometimes
more than negative but when you look
back on the past we have
um we're we're biased towards the
positives you know we that's why we
always say like the good old days you
know the past was always better because
not because it actually was but because
we tend to forget the negative things
faster than we than we do the the good
stuff
so
have any of you ever gone um back to an
x and forgot how toxic it was yeah uh-uh
no no no yeah i only had one narcissist
and then you're like oh that's why i
broke up with you
um okay we're gonna read some super
chats
um sorry guys i know i said i'd be
better about them but if the
conversation's just going well i just
try not to interrupt it um because i'm
just trying to put on the best quality
show for you guys um but i really want
to read these super chats
so um house of haas
five dollars power of the victim when by
the way sorry before i finish i start
these um all the super chats guys i'd
really like to get better lighting in
here like
i just feel like everyone's a little
washed out so that's what i'm using the
super chat money for right now so all
the super chats it really helps the show
oh shoot sorry
my producer is telling me to look at the
camera all the super chats um it really
does help the show and um i i honestly
don't even keep the money at this point
i just
spend it on equipment and lighting so i
really do appreciate you guys supporting
the show because i really couldn't do it
with do it without you
okay
um so yesterday we missed the super chat
from izzy i don't know if you can see
that okay yeah let me let me just
refresh the page
really quick because sometimes they
don't go okay
um
okay so izzy sorry we missed sorry we
missed you last stream pearl i've become
a fan
i wasn't even on the last stream
um please continue the amazing content
continue to advocate for non-modern
women house of hosts power of the victim
when you have the protection of those
with power men are not afraid of women
but they are afraid of the men with the
monopoly on violence um ten dollars from
infrared info vader understand how you
feel and behave often or not the same
you feel like women are constantly
victims but in the real world
in the real world how do modern women
actually behave let's not be delusional
or naive
gus most domestic violence cases come
from lesbian couples and women aren't
afraid of hitting men because they have
never been hit by a man full force
um
american bystander does the panel feel
oh i'm gonna i'm gonna read this at the
end because that's a question um warren
lee search youtube's call
cl i don't know how to say the word
colonel
kurtz depp heard flip the genders it
reverses the gender roles of deaf and
heard audio tapes
it's jfe the reason mainstream didn't
teach women the truth is because
it because the truth
objective of feminism was to sell
products to you all women are the main
consumer base i agree
info vader keep the super hard keep
going super hard peeps we should support
pearl and the messages to help people
get better outcomes and be realistic and
modern entitled clueless society just
human get the likes up gentlemen yes
please guys like the video really helps
with the algorithm yeah we're trying to
get to 400 likes today yes we're at okay
views or above that now so shout out to
you guys
um okay so then um a mario ray214 women
are prisoners of their emotions shut up
i know
the women are prisoners of their
emotions this is why you need fathers to
pick their daughter's husbands because
we as men know if the man is worth a
damn or not um xerox um youtuber lauren
souther covered hair bonding between men
and women the research she looked up
suggested a woman sleeping with one man
is the equivalent of of a man sleeping
with 19 women oh jesus
um
basi pearl what is your biggest
disagreement with the red pill um what
is the single biggest thing the red pill
has taught me
my biggest disagreement is i don't think
cheating is conducive for families and
multiple wives and i think a lot of red
people red pill people go with that um
uh what is the single biggest thing the
red pill has taught you i think just the
dating market like the 80 20 rule i
always thought was really interesting
because that's a girl we don't
necessarily know we're going for the
same guys
um
dragon slayer did the chicken guy really
change or did you
and you're just being delusional in your
remembrances outside sex
i'm going to keep going we can answer
that later possibly okay xerox better
bachelor covered this as well
vasopressin is a naturally occurring
chemical in males that encourages men to
stay with women oxytocin is temporary
for women so they require constant
stoking or kids in the old days and then
the question um
says does the panel feel women suffer
more emotional damage than men and also
before we answer that guys i'm sorry my
dog is being wild right now i don't know
if you can hear it but she's barking a
little bit i'm sorry if you guys can but
yeah do you guys i have an interesting
one okay go ahead so i've always heard
about
men having
um like men never being able to get over
their first love so i feel like men
always have the one that got away but
women don't really like whenever i feel
like i've uh moved on from a
relationship no i mean i've only had
like one serious relationship but i feel
like i've been able to like fully heal
from that and move on
whilst i feel like
i've heard a lot of men speak about how
they're never able to move on so
maybe i feel like women's emotional
response is
greater in the moment
men's is kind of like lived out longer
if that makes sense mm-hmm i'll say i
was going to ask you as a guy you are a
man do you think that's a thing i don't
think that's the thing i think it's more
so discipline amongst a person itself
like if you do not want to get over that
first love that you ever had that is a
choice that you've made yeah like don't
get me wrong people go oh i can't do it
i can't get over them they're the love
of my life but really and truly if that
person is out of your life you've made a
choice as to whether you want to detach
from them or you want to keep that
feeling that feeling can be very
addictive
in its own right so people wanting to
keep it i totally understand but more so
is it conducive for the next
relationship do you know that it's going
to be bad for the relationship and are
you willing to make the changes
necessary in order to ensure that
doesn't happen or it doesn't affect your
next relationship
right
i agree yes i agree i think it depends
on the person and that common i think
it's because you are confident and you
know who you are there's a lot of people
they don't know who they are who they
are and they don't love they don't
self-love themselves enough so that's
why they kind of like get still they are
stuck
like oh my gosh this is my first love i
don't think self-love is like a thing
it is a thing i do self-love myself what
no i think it's like every time i hear a
girl talk about self-love respectfully
this is offensive
i don't get offended but i'm just like
why did your girl talk about self-love
it's just like
her
making
excuses for poor behavior at times well
that's the thing is like you know
that's the problem with all these
buzzwords that start going crazy in
social media like self speaking
like self love and narcissism and i just
feel like there's so many buzzwords that
just get a bad rap because people just
record them in order to
like it's the same thing with astrology
and spirituality and all this like these
are not inherently bad things it's just
like certain people use it as a way to
you know like just justify their bad
behavior and it just like makes it look
bad for everybody but i do feel like
self-love is necessary i mean if you
don't have that then you're just gonna
make choices out of fear like
because when you
uh live through self-love you live
through truly like valuing yourself and
making choices that are good for you and
trying to maintain yourself
away from a fear-based mentality which
is what we were talking about earlier
which i feel like
conduces to the to the bad choices you
know and i also believe that you
if you self-love then you do not seek
validation from people yes you actually
know what you're worth you actually know
what you need and what what is yourself
at least you understand yourself better
you understand your needs so you do not
seek for someone to tell you oh you look
nice today oh um i like you or something
like you actually know your worth so you
wouldn't even lower your expectations as
you said earlier and also you will
understand where you're standing at the
moment i'm not saying self-love as if
you're the best person or just like
reach a point to arrogance but at least
you know what you act where you stand at
the moment so you can understand that
you don't need someone or you do not
seek anything from someone else if that
makes sense so this is just like my
experience with self love like girls
that's about this it's like usually just
a
okay to be delusional
and like kind of outpace where they're
actually at in life
like for example they'll say oh i did
like i love myself i'd like i don't
deserve i'm i'm gonna reject these guys
like i'm above them in some way they
kind of insinuate that's the thing right
but but to me it's like if those are the
guys that are approaching you and
interested in you that's that's what you
deserve because that's what you're worth
it's like what you're like how could i
say like if i if i don't get offered a
job that's a hundred thousand dollars
how can i say oh i'm worth a hundred
thousand dollars but girls will be like
oh i'm 300 pounds but i'm worth a guy
that makes six figures and a six feet
tall and is all this stuff but if you
don't have those men approaching you
like how do you
how can you say you deserve them
that's the thing so self-love shouldn't
reach a certain point that you would
think that you're beyond everyone or
you're above everything it should be
limited because anything excessive is
wrong
right so you should you should know what
your expectations are and you should
know what you're worth at least what
what you expect from people do not go
beyond everything and if someone comes
and it's perfect for you you will be in
a state they'll be like nah i need
someone better do not reach that state
but reach a state where you do not need
someone that would that you know would
treat you badly but still be like oh no
because he said that okay i'm going with
him if that makes sense yeah and i feel
like if you're coming into dating from a
self-love perspective if you're doing it
from like what you just said like
feeling like oh i love myself so i
deserve a guy that's six foot and rich
it's like
well that's not really self-love that's
like being superficial right that's what
feminism has taught people
is that if you love yourself and you
think
you deserve that high value man go for
it
even if you are not in
in that same caliber or doing the things
that you need to do to be with that man
and keep that man it just has taught
taught us that self self love
you can
put yourself on a pedestal and whatever
you think you deserve that's exactly
even if it's astronomical out of this
world just unrealistic it's okay you can
do it because of feminism that's what i
think well and and the other thing i was
going to add is like when you go into a
relationship it's not about you
like it's about like about who got who
who what guy wants to date a girl that's
all about me
most of the girls that spout self love
are selfish is in my experience and you
guys know but that's the thing maybe
this room is the exception i don't know
but in my experience like with those
girls like typically it's about me me me
they don't have anything to offer to a
guy other outside of hooking up they
don't cook they don't clean they don't
like do any of the things i don't cook i
don't know
cardi b that's a perfect example of
someone who would say something like she
does i know i should she actually did a
video and offset was like filming her
probably yeah
she's very humble a lot of these women
say they don't need men and talk down on
men and their music but like back home
what are they doing
like cardi b she's like her music i
don't cook i don't clean we get she's
married she goes back to the cheaters
money she's getting higher and cleaner i
don't know she can't she's a business
that she's promoting yeah she's
promoting you don't need to cook you
know another time but that i think that
line comes from like back in the day
like women they were just meant to be
doing that you know and they were just
being perceived as that as housewives as
cleaners as mothers and shut up and you
don't do anything else and you don't say
and you have no power and that's unfair
you know and that's why i think he came
from from there i don't think it's that
deep personally in regards to those
lyrics she's
in my opinion saying i don't cook i
don't clean because i don't have to like
what what yeah but let me tell you how i
got this ring right w.a.p what you're
saying is true yeah back in the day
women did take on that domestic role but
for that context she's basically
shedding light on the fact of you don't
even need to be able to do the things
that you should want to do for yourself
forget a relationship a husband you
should be able to do that as a bare
minimum for yourself so yeah you know
i think it's i think it's about the
culture though yeah because you know
what that song sounds like it sounds
like i'm not doing it for a guy
like i i think we can like try to wrap
it around and that it's not but come on
like but you are very in favor uh in men
in a relationship but i think when you
are in a relationship it has to be go
both ways oh it's not just me cleaning
and cooking it's not just meeting myself
and it's not just me during the house
you know it's both both have to help or
we hired a cleaner i couldn't
but here's the thing i don't know i said
that i go both ways i tell women leave
the bombs if your guys not working get
out like leave him like don't don't stay
with a bum ass dude but i think it's
both ways like with women like i have
brothers and i i think it's important
that they have standards for women
outside of just being pretty and like
looking nice and like we should try to
earn that the men that we want to be
with so so apart from uh cooking and
cleaning like what else is there
outside of cooking and cleaning i mean
have you ever bought like a nice
thoughtful gift for a guy like for his
birthday yeah it's just like the little
like being a nice like girlfriend like
surprising him
um like i've said that sex is a duty in
a marriage before and that like girls
freak out when i say this
but that like that's part of it and then
you know
anyone can cook and clean but it takes a
wife to make a home
yeah so if you're if you're gonna get
married like my mom always did like
family traditions and she thought it was
really important that she took care of
the home and that every kid felt loved
and you want your husband to feel loved
too
and
um
it's just like
i i think it's just about the mentality
of wanting to make that guy's life
easier instead in some way instead of it
just being about us yeah yeah yeah but
but as like women we're always told like
we're the prize we're the queens and
it's hard to not believe that when
you've heard it your whole life but to a
guy that is like worth the damn you're
not the prize at all he's got like 20 of
you yeah so what are you doing that's
different mm-hmm
um
do we have more super chats i was going
to read something
i think my oh sorry my screen i believe
we do um
wait let me see
okay okay
um okay okay i got it actually one day
pearl's going to have a button it's just
going to do a little super chat i know
i got a button machine thingy so i'm
going to have um
i'll record it
oh i have okay
um
okay ten dollars from affy kingdom much
love and respect sending positive energy
ladies respect to the panel in the chat
room yeah thank you guys we've had a
very nice chat room today though i
appreciate it yeah that is not always
the case
um okay um five dollars from see hang
how often has each of the guests monkey
branched from relationship relationship
um bossy sarah is a legendary host have
him on mar oh he's gonna do tuesdays now
i haven't announced this yet but he's
going to do tuesdays
um pearl what are the top three things
you want in a husband um
i know it's superficial but like my
height-ish or taller like within an inch
or two
um
hard-working
and i know you guys say it's about money
but it's not about money it's about the
mentality of like working hard and like
building something um because that was
just really prevalent in my family and
um it's top three it's hard to pick
three i know this like goes back to like
what you guys say um and i would just
say having similar values so um like
paula like i'm very political obviously
so i think it'd be hard for me to be
with someone that's like on the other
side
um
okay
um tyrell clark it's ironic when women
speak they act like they're the victim
they made the choice to do what they
wanted look what happened to me i flew
to a different
country to have sex and i'm the victim
so i didn't say that
no i know you did it it's okay it's okay
look it's just
why do women um want to front all their
low their load all their impact choices
in their 20s having your kids early will
allow you to pursue a career after the
kids you can look after
zentians other red pill content creators
have said this before men love
idealistically because they are
territorial with their women well women
all love opportunistically to ensure
best resources women get over their man
long before they want to leave um bowsey
pearl would you be
on a top .1 man's rotation or a
completely average wife's man's wife and
why i mean the wife i don't mean a
just be looking good in the corner no
lie oh thank you
sentience it's just vasily pros oh my
gosh vasopressin and oxytocin men create
dopamine and vasopressin during orgasm
while women create secrete dopamine and
oxytocin during orgasm breastfeeding and
childbirth continued oxytocin quickly
bonds women to men while bastiprocin
takes a while to bond men to women thus
men can sleep with women without bonding
while women cannot breaking up on
impairs the ability to pond in the
future
self-love is actually is really about
false confidence of modern women um
[Music]
um i think you may have missed it two
pounds your subs are going crazy like
going like crazy
okay
oh yeah thank you they are
we hit 80k today which was a big deal
um
which i appreciate i didn't even tell
you guys if you don't subscribe i'm out
of it cause i just got back from europe
if you don't subscribe to the channel we
got beef oh my god it's
okay uh we got beef okay y'all i put on
this i work so hard at this show you
already know how hard i work at this
show like seriously hit the subscribe
button it's free it's free it just takes
a second okay
um okay and then dragons salem
1001. differences in sec sex is from in
marriage needs women are materialistic
men think of intangibles like peace
legacy and value um abercadabra thank
you pearly for all you do in this space
stay encouraged and beautiful appreciate
the discussion thank you
did i miss anything
okay
um so the one thing i was going to talk
about today have you guys heard um the
stat that one in five women have been
i don't know if we can say i'll say s-8
or grape um on
either one in five or one and three have
been graped on college campuses have you
heard that
no i think that's weird i think i heard
it like back in the day like
around that statistic yeah
yeah i think i heard it like back when
that um
that thing happened with that boy that
grape the girl and what was his name the
blonde dude
anyways oh i know who you're talking
about in that documentary um yeah tell
me if it was one in five or one and
three hold on let me know in the chat
which one sorry you so you've heard it
you've heard it
no i feel like i've heard something
along the lines
is that
that is that that statistic is from the
states right
is that something that one on five
happens
in
in the uk at all i'm not saying that it
doesn't but is it i don't feel like it
would be the same because i feel like
the college culture in the us is so
different to how it is in the uk
well the what my point was actually that
that stat isn't correct so they've been
misquoting that stat for years wow and
giving because if if one in five women
were getting graped on college campuses
you think your dad would send you to
college
it's like a war zone yeah
they they included if you hooked up with
someone while drunk
oh
so even if the guy was drunk too it's
still
great
in that study
so like you both could be
or if you felt pressured so if a guy's
like pressuring you to sleep with him
and you still chose to like you could
count that as grape
so you're asking girls have you ever had
sex drunk
or been pressured to have sex and did it
so i think one in five women would say
yes to that but that's a completely
different thing than like grape
yeah
so um my question is why
why do you think they like pushed that
stat even though it was so inaccurate
well i'll give you my opinion i think it
was part of an agenda um an agenda in a
sense to kind of
push a narrative that wasn't necessarily
true and they didn't really have hard
facts so what they would have done is
they would have encompassed different
parts of a statistic in order to prove a
point
and whether it was true or not um it
kind of gets their agenda pushed out
there and then people that are ready to
bandwagon will jump on it without even
knowing the
nitty-gritty details of
what actually happened
or maybe it just would it was in a favor
of a situation maybe
like just to consolidate a situation
that happened maybe they just brought
that
start out
if that makes sense do you think the
people that push that stat should be
held accountable for it
for like misquoting like very very odd
like we would agree that that's that's a
poor way to portray it right we would
like i think we'd all agree that
drunk drunk sex
and sex that someone pressured you into
is not the same thing as getting pulled
into a park or something and held down
and like against like those are two
different things yeah yeah so do you
think that the people that pushed those
stats
and ran campaigns on those stats should
be held accountable
yeah 100 percent i mean just imagine
parents responsible because you're
essentially
running a campaign and
doing all this stuff on a lie
and you're not
you're not positively benefiting anybody
because it's a it's a lie and in the end
when all
if it comes back that this stat was a
lie from the beginning and you have to
go back through all this stuff and every
person that
was in your campaign you have to go back
and like prove now was this truth or
this a lie so it's like very nitpicky if
you lie from the beginning and you have
all these years of lying you gotta
somehow either
go back and be like um this is actually
the truth and like explain every single
situation to be truthful or you just
sweep it up under the rug and be like
it's okay
do you think that
it it created fear of men
like pushing that stat
like for for women like do you feel like
it made it kind of played into the men
or trash
narrative yeah
of course it has to be like just imagine
young girls
deciding to go to college what would
they think about it knowing that reading
that statement would make them a bit
like scared of it right i'm talking from
my experience as an international
student if i go for example if i decide
going to college at 18 years old and i i
hear this
i would be scared 100
like because it's not something that we
should take lightly especially just
imagine families reason that your
parents you're maybe the the only girl
in the family and they're sending you a
bro to study and they're reading that
what would they feel about it they will
it's not even you who would be fair
enough men they will actually put their
fear in you that see you shouldn't be
doing this men can be trash like that
man can do this to you don't go out late
at night blah blah blah blah so it can
be cultivated in you as well from family
just by hearing them so it's definitely
wrong and they should be accountable for
it
do you think that women that falsely
accuse men should go to prison
yes about grape yes yeah definitely
speak into the mic please
i would say
it's a tough one yeah i mean
oh i would i will say it
i would base it depending on how dammit
yeah on the damage that it had on the
guys who said like if he had like this
huge career and like that all sort of
like you know was ruined on the base of
that um then i would say yes
but if it was like just some guy and
like it nothing really happened like i
would say
but what about reputation like everyone
on so if a girl does that on campus even
if say say there's no job no he's still
in school whatever
everyone looks at him like can you
imagine walking into a room and having
everyone think you did that yeah and
just because one girl got mad because
you dumped her
yeah
i don't think it should be based on
their
status because
either way if they're this high value
person or they're just some joe schmo
off the street it affects them from
someone negatively saying that they
raped him like that's life-changing and
altering and
it's even worse for someone who cannot
defend themselves in court who can't
afford to defend themselves not saying
that the one that has money it's
easier for them because it's still
detrimental both ways but i i think that
if you lie on someone
in that type of situation you
you should automatically be
penalized for it yeah yeah
or not but there has to be some sort of
repercussions yeah yeah definitely
you should you should pay the
consequences of every action that you do
and if you do that i think
of course if you are a woman or a man
you should pay the consequences it
doesn't for me
a lot of subjects that you talk pearl
it's not for me i don't think as a
gender i think as a as people you know
we are all people we are you know all
sinners in a way nobody is a saint in
the end of the day we are all humans we
do mistakes there's other there's good
people there's bad people
we are sometimes we meet good people and
they get worse and there's sometimes we
met worse people and then after a few
years they get better so it's not about
gender in the end of the day you know um
they're of course biologically as women
and men we are different and when it
comes with privileges
how you say privilege privilege and
conditions and all that yeah it changes
but
when it comes you know to consequences
and all that yeah definitely i mean goes
for both ways well i think that the
point um i because i never say like i
think people are shitty like in general
like i think there's a lot of shitty
people and i think there's oh yeah and
shitty women but the point is that when
when men are shitty there's almost
always a consequence
when women are shitty there oftentimes
is not
because women can hit men in public and
no one really does anything
women can falsely accuse someone
and she's not going to jail she's
getting sued
when she ruined that man's livelihood
the last five years
like women can
oh there is a there's
another issue which is like father's
rights too like there's a woman in the
u.s who gave her kid up for adoption
and the dad wanted to be in his life
and the dad like wanted the kid and she
could legally give that kid up for
adoption because she was a woman because
that was in the u.s
a woman or a man well i think the law um
i don't know i don't know we have to
think about that
it could be men passing this these laws
but that's not the point the point is
that the justice system and i would
guess it's similar here i don't i don't
know the uk but i would guess it's
similar here because where a gynocentric
social order is everywhere
and and
in custody cases
like a a woman has to be a terrible
mother to lose the kid the like the the
woman almost always gets it
when it should it should just be 50 50.
and if and then a girl can also
sleep with a guy get a kid out of him
like like trap a guy
and if she doesn't want the kid she can
have an abortion but if the man doesn't
want like to be a part of his life he
can't do anything he has no what do you
mean the woman trapped the guy and then
she does it i i do understand what are
you saying drake the drake incident
where the girl was taking the condom and
putting hot like like he put the hot
sauce in it uh yeah so like women can do
things like that and if if he caught her
doing that that means other girls have
done it and so they've done that yeah
because because that's that's the thing
if something comes to the forefront that
means in society it's been happening
so girls can can trap a guy or tell him
he's on birth control get a kid out of
him and force that man to pay child
support for 18 years
and girls will cheer each other on to do
this
they'll cheer you on social media like
get that bag get that check
yes
no no that's that's another way to get
that back no like what the hell what are
you getting for brittany renner she said
if you really want to catch a check you
go sleep with an nba player because they
don't use condoms oh no because she's
the one that had the babies
yeah yeah she's like yeah yeah and
that's like
like and nobody there was no outrage no
nothing and so now that man's on the
hook for child support like i don't
understand why we even have child
support you're a girl you can work like
what the
is there something stopping you from
working yeah like so we have and and on
top of that there's there's laws where
men are stuck in child support like if a
man loses his job he still has to pay
child support even if he can't afford it
and they're they're gonna pay then
he goes to jail yeah if he doesn't
like so he's not even able to
or men men don't have access to their
children because they just give him to
the mother and they'll go to court for
years
fighting like like trying to be a part
of the kid's life and they just can't
because the judgmental system is so
skewed what kind of dumb woman trapped a
man that he's broke and tried to get the
child out of here well the point is he
might not have been broke to start so
let's say if a guy was making six
figures makes sense and she says you
have to pay 50 of your income or 25
let's say 25 percent of your income has
to go to the mother of your kids
yeah of a month then he loses his job
he can't pay it yeah so now what
now he's got child support payment
payment payment payment
and
it's like it this ruins men's livelihood
so like the whole point of my show isn't
necessarily to say because i could go on
and on about the like the shitty things
men there there are some shitty toxic
magnets talk about that yeah they keep
spelling but the thing is we do like in
every other media source we always talk
about the man
all the time yeah but the thing is
sometimes i do feel pearl you talk on
behalf of men always more most of the
times
than women and you are a woman
and yeah it's great that you are seeing
their point of view and it's great you
know to point out you know what
just it should be for men as well and i
completely agree with that because we
are in the end of the day we are all
human people
doesn't mean you're if you're a man or a
woman for me we are all people and i
think everyone deserves to be respected
and be treated as the same
um but
most of the times what i
hear from your um
from your channels it's always like you
come from the men's side
you know and you are a woman and
sometimes you do comments based on women
that they are a bit
how would i say
um
low
okay so which comments like for example
there's a post recently that you post
and you said um about
fat women
the whales the whales yeah yeah so for
example
um if you were fat
i was fat
so yeah so let's say i met you when you
were fat
and i would call you a whale
i wouldn't do that because it's not my
person um i think everyone is a you know
is a human again and we have all
feelings
and my for example my mom she actually
got a bit of weight
because of medication there's a lot of
people they become the whales that you
call
that i don't
uh think that is right to call a woman
just because she's fat because it's post
depression partum you know or because of
medication or because of mental health
this is what we do and i think this is
what but we're doing it again you're
taking away accountability she's fat
because she ate too much when i was fat
it was because i ate too much and yeah
but there's the reason why people ate
too much probably because people bully
other people or probably depression or
probably they had
family problems in their house going on
and they cannot cope
it's
a mechanism no no for them to cope with
a lot of pressure everyone is different
and we should not judge my show how
people like my show you can't this is my
show why weren't they like that in the
1950s
so so i'm saying people are fatter today
the people are the same but in the 1950s
they were thinner
why yeah why
there's more tv probably i don't know
yeah so a choice
and that's that's what it comes down to
that's a choice
if you're if you're fat that's a choice
it's a choice to eat more calories in
your burning i've been fat
okay and it was my choice and i and i
lost that that was your case it doesn't
mean that everyone went through the same
experience as you because everyone went
through different experiences for
different reasons to get fat i mean to
your car you're looking for exceptions
rather than the rule
like you're looking for the exception
most people are fat because they eat too
much
and don't accept that's how they get
yeah you have to eat too so right and so
when i say what i was talking about in
that post was leaving the whales so if a
girl i was talking about if you if a
girl gets a ring okay and then she's 120
and she decides to gain 100 pounds to
220. i said leave the whale because i'm
sorry you you made the choice to gain
100 pounds that's disrespectful to your
husband
and you know you you can disagree with
calling her a whale but like what else
you going to call her that's that's
that's a big woman
big woman that would be better i could
and i know that this isn't the topic but
the one thing i've noticed about um
just the way
that
the way pearl thinks and the way pearl
expresses herself is
not normal to
a regular woman because this is not how
we talk and so when i first met pearl
there were some things that she she was
saying i'd be like oh
and then like as i've gotten to know her
and like seen her podcast and seeing
everything i'm like this is this is
pearl she does not hold back she does
not um she does not she just speaks it
how it is and how and how it is yes
there are some
some things that she has said that may
come off offensive but that's how she is
we don't if a man was talking like this
we wouldn't be like oh this that in the
third because
that's how men are they just say it how
it is and so i'm not saying
that
i'm just saying that's how that's how
her opinion is and that's how that's
pearl and then you you have your own
opinion yeah but i'm not saying that i'm
not um i'm not respecting your opinion i
just say that i don't agree with her
and she asked me an example and i said i
gave it to her and that's it i'm not i'm
not creating a beef i have nothing again
this is part of the podcast it's okay
yeah yeah yeah i'm just saying i just
gave my opinion based on your opinion
you so my question for you do you feel
like i was incorrect do you think a
woman should be able to gain all the
weight she wants
not disrespectful i don't think women
they think i'm like oh my god i'm going
to eat so much today because i want to
become so fat but at some point nobody
does things that let themselves
get there yeah like at some point
there's a point where it becomes a
choice like i'm not saying yeah
definitely that's like your body's gonna
my mom had seven kids she doesn't look
the same as she did when she was 22. but
the thing is she's always tried to stay
in shape the best she could and look
good for my dad so my whole point was
like it wasn't about the whale
although it kind of makes it funny or
she's laughing
some people yeah like yeah
and like the point the point is that
like like men deserve to have standards
and so the whole point of my channel
isn't to [ __ ] on women it's to just talk
about like the unfair standards that
like men are held but there's a lot of
men as well after they get married
there's a big belly there huh oh a lot
of beard on the
and even even before they get married
there is men out there even young men i
see these skinny tall men like they you
know
pregnant for five months and we ask oh
it's beer can i they're proud that's
nice
but a woman she's all sexy she's all
good she has a great body and we kind of
have like to be like forcing her stomach
like when we sit when we sit we have
that to force ourselves to not show any
fat otherwise we're going to be judged
you are too fat or your titties are just
skinny or to that so women are more
punished uh by other women and men
how they look but men they can have a
big [ __ ] nose
like [ __ ] a [ __ ] bridge eyes hot
eyes
or having a big belly no no no no no no
no no no no no i i i observe a lot i am
not i observe a lot because he probably
women and men are judged i observe a lot
i'm gonna tell you that women and men
are judged on different categories
so so like a man can be overweight and
unattractive but if he makes enough
money a woman will overlook it yeah i
could be you know rich off this podcast
tomorrow not every man with a big belly
is like doing monies oh no i know but
like sometimes sometimes we wish uh he
they wish
anyway but yeah i'm just saying the the
men they even before marriage or after
marriage
they don't care either there's men out
there they don't care either okay i was
all for equality of leaving yeah i was
offered both ways because i feel like we
we have to understand that a
relationship
uh even though it should be based on
love initially like
your partner is an extension of yourself
and
they they're like an ambassador for you
you know what i mean and you're an
ambassador for them so it's like if you
truly respect your partner you want to
make them look good and therefore you
will take care of yourself like
and if your partner starts to let
themselves go then
you have to be like hey like you know
we're not looking good here like
i mean this is especially true for like
celebrity couples and stuff but even
people who are not in the public eye
like it's just something to be realistic
about and you know a lot of people might
say like oh that's superficial
or whatever but like we do
like superficiality is a part of life
like it shouldn't be the whole basis of
your relationship but like
i don't feel like true love means that
you can just love yourself at any like
shape or size you know what i mean
because it's like
it's important to look after yourself
yeah because essentially if you are
if you are overweight and not able to do
daily things in life you're not going to
be able to do the things you need to do
for yourself one but also for your
partner in your relationship because
of your health your health is like
number one for everything because if
your health isn't in check and your
health isn't in order you're not going
to be able to be a
functioning human being
and i think that's something that people
forget when they say hey you're you're
unhealthy how dare you say that to me
like no like we want you to be healthy
we want you to be able to
be a human and operate
correctly to instead of being unhealthy
and having setbacks and you're not the
best version like
you know how you are like when you're
insecure about your body like you're the
worst version of yourself like i i am
the nicest person when i feel skinny let
me like like i am the nicest kindest
like you can't say [ __ ] to me when i
feel skinny
but it's like when like and i've had
guys where they'll say i'm still
attracted to the big girls but i won't
date them because they're just
exhausting because they're so insecure
all the time yeah that's so true but
there's a lot of women they have great
bodies and they still have insecurities
as well
yeah everyone has insecurities you know
yeah i mean those the guys i talked that
i've talked to about this just say
there's more when you're bigger
which i think kind of makes sense but
there's a lot of guys as well they like
big
it's just i think they say again
they settle for big they don't they
don't like it
they just settle for it like any guy
find me a movie star that's dating a
lizzo
um like a guy there's another oh what's
her name uh the blonde one she's very
she's very funny she's an actress no
humor but she's not that strange no no
i'm talking about that i find me uh
find me a guy that has a ton of options
that's like hot that that is good money
has all this stuff going for him
and find me a guy like that that picked
a girl that's big yeah she might have a
big bum but yes
big boobs big bomb
just like if a girl looks like a model
like typically she goes for a rich guy
successful
or tall like it's just you know that's
what it is
yeah yeah i have a question for you
pearl because
i mean i i agree with a lot of things
that you say and
i admire how you sometimes like give
facts that don't necessarily favor you
and my question is like how do you
cope with for example i hate the
statistic like i know that it's true but
i hate it the one that um
men find like men of all ages find women
from 18 to 24 more attractive which by
the way i've read the other half of that
um
of that study which states that even
though
men of all ages find women between 18
and 24 more attractive they would
actually rather have a relationship with
a woman that's closer to their age but
either way like um
you're 25 right
so like when you see statistics like
that like how how do you deal with like
the the feelings that come up of like oh
[ __ ] like you know what i mean like oh
it bothers me i don't enjoy it like it's
not fun
i don't enjoy that like it's like we
don't tend to get better looking with
age but i like the way i deal with it is
you can't do anything about it you look
how you look and it's really just
comparison like you're how old are you
23 23 oh oh wow okay so you're in that
category i mean
just about to leave it but yeah but like
i mean you're you're more attractive
than most girls like i like that's how i
recruit for the show no i seriously like
i pick i pick girls that i think are
pretty and i like or guys that are like
because it's entertainment like i get
better views the better looking the
girls are and so you're still going to
probably be more attractive than most
girls even at 30 like you'll just be a
little less attractive than you are now
but
i mean i think i think the point is like
you just want to find a husband because
once you have a husband who cares
yeah like the only person that needs to
find you attractive is your husband sure
and again i just deal with it like
i can't do it i can't get younger
so all i can do is date the best like
the most intentionally i can try to get
in the best shape that i can because if
you're in good shape you're still in the
top like 25 of women in the u.s probably
more here you guys aren't as fat but
but like like what else are you supposed
to do but i think it's just when you are
making like the choices to date as
intentionally as you can like you feel a
lot better about yourself because you're
not like wasting time yeah like i felt
so much better when i broke up with my
last boyfriend because i was like okay
i'm not i'm not wasting my time anymore
and it's like less you know like you
could be married in a year you never
know
please it's not good does that answer
jesus is like me i'm walking away from
today thinking oh my god i need to like
find someone quick 21's got somebody
i've got 25's
same i'm like you look great i can't
believe you're in you're gonna start
lying i will give you 25.
max 24.
give it to you that's the attractive
the attractive range what was it
to me it's like to me it's like these
facts are hard to hear at first but when
you have all the information and you
like because again i've the reason i can
talk like this is because i've heard it
all
but like oh my gosh if you watch my old
reaction videos guys i'd watch some i'd
be like
the wall what's the wall
you guys
it's complex
that's a whole nother conversation but
but you just start to get like okay this
is the bed this is like at least i know
now and i can you know date more
intentionally now rather than later
yeah that's also like based on reality
and not like some some fantasy though
yeah
rather than wake up at 40 and be like
where's my high value man
going off of that i have a question for
all the ladies here if you knew these
stats say like in high school there was
a class that taught you about um
just a
womanhood and what actually happened
stats and all this stuff would you have
dated more intentionally when you were
younger
versus yeah what you did
definitely
i think we should have a class
in high school how to date men and men
how to date women
and how to value yourself and what you
look what are you looking for and who
you are i think that's so important
but um yeah in high school or even at
school i think they should have teach a
lot of things to prepare us for life not
just when it comes to dating or
relationships
but yeah definitely and can i just add
yeah a class would be all good and well
but
you could have that class be dating
intentionally and still meet a
non-starter it just
i guess gives you a
i don't know more of a growth mindset as
opposed to a fixed one when it comes to
a relationship because through my 20s i
dated intentionally i was just
unfortunate to me you know did you did
you involve did you involve your dad
um
so on that subject
for some families and households your
dad being involved is not your choice in
my upbringing my dad being involved or
not being involved
had nothing to do with him it was more
sorry nothing to do with me it was an
issue between
him and my mom my dad wasn't around
maybe having my dad around yeah would
have definitely maybe impacted different
decisions that i've gained
but not everybody has that luxury so
yeah well that's that's like um i think
we as women would do a lot better if we
had our dad's input more and if we did
because i started um after the last
relationship i got out of my dad like
warned me a little bit about it and i
didn't listen and i like literally
now guys i go on dates with or whatever
i tell my dad about them he gets so
irritated because he's like i have
better things to do but his advice has
actually been like
really helpful
because he can't like even if you're
just describing the guy to your dad like
or maybe it's not your dad but like
another male figure like i think men can
see through other men's like yeah [ __ ]
yeah better yeah
yeah because a guy will whisper sweet
nothing's into our ear but like the dad
will be like did he do this did he do
that did he do any of that he doesn't
like you like yeah i mean unfortunately
for me i didn't have
that option yeah um growing into an
adult i guess i've i've been really
blessed with some good
male friends that can kind of give me
their
their opinions let's say um
but in reflection
you know if my dad had have been
the type of man that
had those characteristics and traits to
be able to
tell me what to do and what not to do
then you know who knows where i would be
but you know it's just circumstance
unfortunately there's not
because as women we tend to remember
yeah
ice cream
always
so yeah i think as women we we kind of
have the tendency of
daydream and romanticize things over
about like relationships and men
and i think we felt like a
male figure present in our life our
father i didn't as well
uh maybe my outcome in men it would be
better yeah at least i did a good a good
choice my ex of seven years i'm glad
and i'm gonna i've been respectful as
well but
my dad personally he
shouldn't be as well good arrested soul
shouldn't be a spokesperson for anyone
to be completely honest with you like
his
relationship with my mom i was very
young with
um certain things that went on however
as an adult i've tried to avoid
men like him but then come straight into
contact with men like him and because i
didn't know how to
i don't know like emotionally deal with
it you know you're just in a vicious
cycle of
shitty day
you know what this makes me think of
like how important it is for us to pick
good men to raise our kids
because if we
yeah like
and um because like your mom picking the
wrong guy had so many ramifications for
you definitely and you know it probably
wasn't intentional maybe she didn't have
like a dad either i don't know
it's funny that you say that yeah my
granddad he passed away
when my mum was really young so she
didn't have that
that male figure and then my nan god
bless her she
the sacrifices that you make for your
children she worked a lot so there
wasn't don't have the male presence and
with the greatest respect
not that much of a female motherly
presence because you know your mum's
doing the best that she can to try and
provide for you but
i don't know the hand i was dealt what
can i say yeah because it becomes how is
your mom supposed to teach you how to
find a guy exactly and would you believe
her if like if she couldn't pick a good
guy yeah yeah if only i've gotten older
that i'm more understanding to those
elements but when you're young
the the mind's a crazy thing where your
mind can go and the things that you feel
you deserve and the hands that you've
dealt it's just i don't know as an adult
now i can understand exactly where she's
coming from but let's say what five six
years ago it's just kind of like
whoa with me pity party for one yeah no
and it's um but it almost like
at least now we know you know we can try
to make better decisions in the future
but it's better than like
lying to women and saying
no we make great choices on our own
like because i i don't and i've had a
lot better results since i've involved
my dad and i wish i did it sooner i
think it would have avoided me a lot of
like heartbreak to be honest yeah
so
i think everything comes down to
childhood how we've been raised and then
you know if we don't stop the
i would call
um how you say
cycle
yeah like the
[Music]
it's a cycle yeah you have to break the
cycle and you have to learn from your
past i that's what i look back because
um
i was actually once um pregnant and i
did an abortion and because it was
because i didn't see my partner it would
be a great father to have that kid
because i know
me growing up without a father and
knowing who is my father who was a
nominizer
my mom she raised me by herself
even though she was
not in a great
uh
i mean financially
you know um
she did raise me very well and i
appreciate that but the thing is i look
back and i'm like
this would be my
greatest example to look in the future
to s that would inspire me and see
what's the best guy out there to be the
dad of my kids
and when i got pregnant and i did the
abortion it was because of that it got
me to think
not just because of my career
that impact i mean that was
come to it as well but
it was because as well i didn't see him
as the perfect father and husband for
myself and for my kids i heard a man say
once that if you
if you cannot see yourself having a
child with whoever you're dating or
whoever you're talking to
you have you should not be with him yeah
break up with him
and
don't talk to them and i was like
that is so
true
because so many women
romanticize and fantasize and see this
person that they're with but they don't
realize that if i'm engaging in sex with
this person there's a possibility that
we can have a child together and if
that's something that i do not see with
that person i should not be with them
even if it's rainbows and butterflies in
every other situation if you cannot
see yourself taking care of a child with
that person you should not be with them
michael jackson said it the best
if you um oh yeah how does the lyrics go
um
if you if you can't have a baby
then if you can't feed your baby yeah
yeah if you can't feed your baby don't
have a baby like if you cannot see
yourself with that person
no you should not be with him i don't
know that's easier said than done though
because sometimes when you're in the
midst of the
shitty relationship it's just
the fine line between reality and the
perception of
i mean i'm talking from experience but
it's just like i mean it's it's easier
said than done but then we have to
accept the consequences yeah complain
about the hand we're dealt yeah so like
you you said you're in your 30s yep and
you're single because you made those
choices most definitely yeah and you
know i don't regret those choices
however they're also those elements
some choices i don't i don't regret
because
it's i would take back every shitty
relationship if i could because
i don't know
obviously it's not
you learned a lot as well i definitely
learned a lot just in regards you are
more aware being accountable and just
self-healing there's certain things that
i had to experience to just be a bit
more vulnerable and understanding and
calm so yeah maybe i would
take a different path with certain
things but it's just it's not a regret
everything that happened
to me happened the way it was supposed
to happen
[Music]
um i'm gonna read some super chats this
is a really good conversation guys um
let's see where do you remember the last
ones
that was the one where he said i was
sexy
[Laughter]
it was abracadabra abracadabra was the
last one
i keep accidentally fiddling with this
and like
exiting out of the whole thing and then
i lose my spot
um
i've had quite a few cents
okay justice and the good okay okay
oh wait it wasn't
jess is in the corner looking good no
lie that wasn't the last one oh i know
it's after
i was playing oh okay okay okay
um bowsey ten to thirty percent of essay
claims are fabricated and false
women want to revoke consent post
consenting
just human saying women were forced to
homemaking women worked makes it sound
like men were living their best lives
there wasn't a 40 hour work work weeks
people were paid less than a dollar a
day and the work was
was mostly deadly addressed the whole
past
women who make bowsey women who make
false essay grape claims need to go to
jail we need legislative changes asap
see hang yo this woman was proven i
think in italian courts rogan episode
mentioned a group of scientists were for
not saving people in earthquakes
and predicting with accuracy
accountability needs range um bowsey men
lose their jobs family reputation um
over false essay grape claims even if
he's shown to be innocent the damage is
irreparable um jonathan larosa grape is
massive any false accusation should
definitely be put in jail even if
acquitted you are not proven guilty that
doesn't mean you didn't do it
legends of society i think it is tough
to penalize false accusations because
unless it's without a shadow of a doubt
a lie we can be punishing someone
innocent a real victim and if there is
no
if there is no known punishment for
lying five dollars um from av you need
to frame the question if the man was
accused of
of grape was your son how should the
woman be dealt with a death penalty
sorry
i was just thinking about my brothers
oh okay um legends of society the false
accuser will just take it to the grave
instead of coming forward knowing you're
going to get in trouble would require a
lot of moral and resolve to tell the
truth which women don't have christopher
sertic um
the fact that you ladies don't know
these things about child support in
custody says that all divorce is slavery
for fathers
and a retirement plan for women who file
for a divorce 80 plus percent of the
time
bowsey pearl if you marry the type of
man you want when he wanted you to give
up your youtube channel would you
i'd run it
why you'd work for me
i still run
that's what i was thinking i was like
i'd probably go behind the scenes i
worked so hard on this
um uh pearl don't let the guests over
talk you bowsey um tim nero pearl
speaking on heaven of us men isn't
because women don't listen to men what
she we say on how we are being treated
she is listening to us understanding the
stats we are guys who have been treated
like [ __ ] and it isn't the last straw
jess what are the top three things you
want in a husband
uh
read the rest of super chats
speaking on behalf autocorrect is crap
um
oh another question for jess okay we'll
come back to this at the end um lorenzo
pearl is speaking across the aisle to
the women who genuinely don't know or
don't care about men's struggles thank
you pearl big big woody some
you guys you're killing me with these
names samaj gopro go you are championing
legit reasonable men by calibrating the
feminine imperative keep us
sewaging the ruthless views held by
today's women i'm sorry guys i can't
read um jonathan larussa hormonal weight
gain is not as common if you eat too
much and don't exercise you will get fat
fat is not a bad word it's a description
women have standards a guy physically
cannot change bowsey gaining weight is
not acceptable for either partner but is
worth worse for the women to gain weight
as their image is important for a man's
attraction men never talk about broke
women
pearl what is the shortest height a man
you would marry if all color qualities
were on point uh maybe five ten um
i'm six foot so i'm like five ten like
two inches shorter than me sorry that's
reasonable
six foot
okay um bowsey um a below average
looking woman has more options than an
above average man men um our only option
to level up looks looks money status
game just human you're up there changing
lives good work um zach mc magnoddy men
and women care about different things
and a partner but we all deserve to set
our own standards let's just be honest
about what we want and be willing to
change as much as you would expect with
someone to change for you bowsey pearl
hypothetically what age would you want
to have married and what age would the
man be um i wish i got married 22 to my
high school sweetheart like my parents
did if i had it
up to me like that's like i wanted to
meet my husband in college but it just
didn't you know work out like that um
bowsey pearl's dad sounds like an
absolute chad um marcus infinity women
date men like their father if they don't
know their father they'll pursue men
that the media tells them are valued jim
we should start teaching the socratic
massive oh my gosh method again and
some sort of baseline stats class
personal opinions and experience should
not be considered when examining a
society as a whole informator question
for the panel
um
uh would you rather know the
uncomfortable truth or remain in
blissful ignorance that's why red pill
content is important um maybe we'll come
back to that later bowsey pearl what
opinion is the uk sexual age of consent
16 uh that's gross um if herbert
williams if you're feeling about a way
about
getting to that age you need to compare
it to men we know that we need to do
better and to attain certain areas to be
more attractive in other ways getting
more money and working out is always
typical for us
that's a lot of super chats
okay um jess what are the three things
you look for in a husband and what
ideologies do you disagree with
from me
oh okay
um
the three
um
tall because i'm i'm a tall girl i'm a
tall i'm not talking about what i'm like
i wanna i want somebody tall whatever um
but
she
um
at least at least six six foot plus i'm
not i'm not as tall as pearl
unfortunately i'm in the five foot range
but i'm in the the high caliber
range
um so tall and then um ambition in all
areas um
whether that's ambition to work out
towards your career whatever that may
look like towards um relationship family
all that ambition i need you to
want something for your life before i
get into it because if i'm the only
person or if i'm like the thing you want
in life what else what else do you want
because
i wasn't there all the time
and then um
probably the same
values as me there's so many you say the
same thing yeah
yeah
because i could be nitpicking but he
gotta be funny he gotta do this that and
third but like the overarching theme the
overarching things is i would like for
him to be tall
um ambition and
the same values because i feel like if
all those are aligned and
um
equal then
other things will come
i should have put no kids
yeah yeah yeah you have no children
so what do you disagree with from the
red pill
i don't i don't know because i feel like
i'm still like she's still learning and
so
um
i don't know because there's been things
that initially i'll be like oh how dare
you and then i like sit on it and i
think about it i'm like hmm
you have a point
and so it's the red pill for women in
like a nutshell yeah like the
audacity but then you listen and you're
like oh yeah
i forgot what you had said something one
time and i was like okay whatever pearl
like you don't know what you're talking
about and then i thought about it
afterwards and i was like
she has a point she has a point i was
arguing the other point the next
challenge yeah yes yes you did it was
the men are better than women at
basketball men are better than women at
basketball you like freaked out yeah i
was like how dare you and then i thought
about him like your face was so funny
we're gonna react to it this week
um we just got a fifty dollar stupid
pool
look at guys you don't even understand
these super chats are so important to
the show like we cannot do equipment
upgrades without the super chat so i i
seriously i know you guys there's a lot
of people that watch for free
sorry i look this way there's a lot of
people that watch for free
and no one even has to send money at all
so the people that do like i it
thank you i appreciate it so much um
okay
um
um question
oh gosh there's a lot more super chats
okay
oh wow pretty duper chats oh wow okay
okay um phillip pearl i remember you
calling kevin samuels for advice and i
just found your podcast salute for your
success
um just as a
bowsey justice
you got a little crush just as a solid 8
10 needs to be upgraded to the middle of
the self
[Laughter]
um
xanax we're guarding pearls of parents
with ali and coco what does the panel
think love is and let should love be
pursued or something that you fall into
oh my gosh guys you have so many panel
questions um question for the panel
should people
fight slash are you in a relationship or
not because most lasting successful
marriages last you to having arguments
and disagreements um zentian says fifty
dollars um stop blaming childhood or
outside factors for your current
situations if you claim to be an adult
self-reflect get help and self-improve
not doing it not doing so perpetuates a
victim mentality improve yourself before
asking others to do the same dang okay
um okay we'll do one or two more
questions
um
i'll do i'll do a question for the panel
um should people fight and argue in a
relationship or not because most lasting
successful relationships have fights
so do you think being like if you want a
long marriage do you think fighting is
okay personally i don't like i don't
like fighting not fighting not at all
like if you have different
opinions about something
and if it does come to a point that you
start to talk an incas into a fight i
think it's
one of them it's smart enough like to
leave you know the room and not getting
to a physical or emotional
like really you know up there and then
people just explode and no i think one
should leave
i feel like
we're only human yeah you know you might
find exactly you might not find just the
way that you
communicate and deal with whatever
disruptions occurring in your
relationship so
should people fight well no but we're
only human
i just feel like in a long marriage
you're gonna there's gonna be years
where you don't really that's what i'm
saying
are we supposed to fight or not because
it's duration it can happen any day you
can't just be like oh today i wake up
and i wouldn't fight at any cost but
then you end up fighting over coffee you
never know yeah because it's just like
life you're spending so much time with
that person and you get to know the
person better when you spend more time
with them in the same room so
that's that's it about it yeah i feel
like when you have disagreements sorry
um
you can go at it two ways like some
people they say in fights like in
battles like sometimes you're either
fighting for to win or you're fighting
for peace you know
so sometimes like you fight like just
because you want to be right like you
just want to win the fight but like if
you approach it from that way like it's
always going to be a losing battle you
know you have to fight for peace you
have to look to resolve the issue rather
than you know just trying to prove that
you're yeah exactly you have to put your
ego aside and like truly because even
though yeah you might have moments in
the marriage where you don't like each
other and you have to accept that like
you'll go through those cycles
but it's like what do you really want at
the end of the day like
you want peace like that's what you
should strive for
i think i think fighting is important in
a relationship and the key is how you
repair after the fight yep it's how you
mend the relationship after if you have
a fight and then go to bed like on
opposite ways without resolving the
issues at hand after you fought then
you're going to have problems within
your relationship yeah i like to sleep
at all i like i feel like you should go
to bed angry
what why would you have a like i just
think when you're angry you say things
you regret so i'd rather just like cool
off maybe go to bed and like talk about
it the next day when we're both calm so
sleeping the same bed like and be i mean
i think if it's like you go to sleep in
a different like if you have a really
bad fight like i would rather cool off
because i don't want to say anything i
regret because i'm angry and emotional
and i know as a woman like we get
emotional so i like my mama has a rule
where she told me growing up to if you
still are mad about it after two days
then say something but like
if if
in two days you don't care it probably
wasn't that important no i agree i think
more so my main point of emphasis is
just how you go about repairing after
the fight so it doesn't have to be
straight after
it can be a cool down but more so how do
you repair your relationship after the
fight
cause some people don't even repair
after a fight they
have a fight they go on about it and
there's no fixing it and they have
another fight and it's built off of the
brokenness of this fight in this fight
and this fight and it just
builds up until years later someone's
bringing up something that happened
years ago and you're like i thought you
were over that no i was never over it
it's like well why didn't you talk about
it
and also just thinking about someone
taking the lead to resolve the issue
it's not like you're less important or
you don't have respect or
you have less ego or anything it just it
makes you
it makes you a better person in your own
eyes that yes you took something to
resolve it yeah so whoever is resolving
the issue is they can delete resolve the
issue she didn't think that oh my god
now she would be thinking or he would be
thinking that i don't have ego or i'm
i'm less important or something like
that because thanks to you the problem
would be resolved
um okay i'm gonna read the last super
chats and i think this was um and like
this was probably my favorite show would
you agree this is like the best show
we've done rachel i think this is the
most favorite show i've ever done um you
guys were honestly such great guests you
were such good sports and i really
enjoyed that we can have a conversation
about like stuff that may be
is uncomfortable without getting super
emotional and heated so
great guests um you guys should all come
back
why don't we go around tell the people
where they can find you and then after
that i'm going to do super chat so if i
mean plug it plug yours
plug everything out
um you can find me on instagram it's
dot under nope
it's dot ya dot
girl underscore jess there we go um and
then you can find me on youtube as well
at it's your girl jess
and she just posted up
i did i just posted a vlog from me going
back home to california so if you want
to check that out go ahead there'll be
more coming
what are you gonna do what else tell
them
behind the scenes oh yes behind the
scenes sorry i was like
i'm gonna do behind the scenes of the
show preparation and just a whole bunch
of other stuff so if you want to see
more of me
then go ahead and subscribe to my
channel
so me um marcia my instagram is marcia
tch and aaa so marcia now
and i'm actually thinking to become a
youtuber i'm kind of liking the limbo
because i want to focus on my career as
an actor and i think a youtube
channel it will take
a lot of me
and
yeah but i'm i'm confident that i will
make i will make a youtube channel so
then soon soon i will share my youtube
channel with you guys
um cool so i'm on instagram as at least
tigra that's spelled l-i-s-e-y-t-i-g-r-a
and i'm a musician singer guitar player
so i'd really appreciate your support on
youtube as well amazing
um instagram and at i am a and e and
it's called dt that's it
hi guys my instagram is neymar news
official
you can look forward to seeing some
music from myself i sing i wrap and also
look out for my company for vanity's
sake we do surgical and unsurgical
treatments
for your desire lovely oh yeah
[Music]
i do oh
yeah i mean i'm not gonna lie my social
media is not as savvy as it should be
but i'm learning okay
let me i'm gonna refresh the super chats
and just see if there's any more i know
i know as i said you i know a lot of
people watch for free i don't always
donate every time i watch so i
appreciate when people do send donations
so i want to make sure i read them all
sorry i'm sorry i'm not i'm used to the
one over there
um okay
uh
it was after sentience zach magnotti i'm
dropping another five for y'all for
keeping it real like i looked at the
right camera clockwise um
lmao russian bay is crazy but she's
funny af
pearl if i wanted to start a reaction
channel could i use your content yeah
you could you guys can always react to
my content i'm not like some people you
know what i'm not gonna say
i'm not gonna say it no no they're all
pretty there won't be any copyright
strikes from me partially because i
don't know how to do it and second i
don't care enough to go
dance um okay
but don't don't be re-uploading just the
clips that's annoying that's that i will
copyright you for but if you're reacting
that's that's a new piece of content um
okay
um human love solidarity tommy
coin a mate
ahmed official video um brian woodbridge
pearl you're a breath of fresh air glad
i found you all i think sometimes
arguing is needed but it depends
what you are fighting about and why and
then just a sticker from james not even
a message look at that thanks for i'm
refreshing it one more time just to make
sure i'm not missing anybody don't think
i am okay
okay guys um
thank you so much for watching this is
actually one of my favorite shows um
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
i really want to hit 100k this month um
i'm at eight we're about to hit 81 000
which is crazy
um because we just hit 80k before the
show started so hit that subscribe
button ring the notification bell turn
on your notifications while you're at it
so you can be notified every time we're
live
um
and like the video on your way out
because the likes really help with the
algorithm leave a comment let me know
what we should talk about next show and
i will talk to you guys next time
[Music]